questa sera vorrei condividere con voi
alcuni pensieri sulla professione che
faccio da alcuni anni da molti anni in
realtà che una professione che
sinteticamente potremmo descrivere come
quella del progettista ora
terminologicamente parlando parlare di
progettazione capisco possa essere non
così puntuale non così specifico ma
esiste una sorta di vertigine del
dizionario per cui se parliamo di design
in italia ci si riferisce quasi sempre
solo a dei prodotti degli oggetti
materiali
in realtà il termine che di derivazione
inglese che a sua volta deriva invece
dal latino intenderebbe identificare
delle attività che vanno molto al di là
della produzione materiale fisica di
oggetti ma che riguarda sicuramente dei
principi tali per i quali alla fine
possiamo immaginare prime tre atti delle
strategie delle modalità per cercare
attivamente di utilizzare la
progettazione come strumento di
trasformazione sociale
ecco questo è il punto che a me
personalmente interessa è questo il
punto sul quale vorrei soffermarmi con
voi per alcuni minuti questa sera la
prima slide che dietro le mie spalle
porta una sorta di piccolo titolo
introduttivo che mi piacerebbe dare a
questa micro chiacchierata ho giocato
con il titolo del the licks di
quest'anno no invece di revolutionary
road evolution road perché l'evoluzione
che è contenuta nella rivoluzione credo
spieghi molto tantissimo nella modalità
attraverso la quale un bravo progettista
contemporaneo possa mettere in atto con
la strategia di cambiamento di
trasformazione sociale di cui parlavo
prima
il sottotitolo dice designers and humans
sempre ad revolution il design deve
essere immaginato come una rivoluzione
certo lo vedremo insieme spero ma credo
che non bisogna mai perdere
di vista l'idea che si è accentrato
sull'essere umano
ora se noi scorriamo il dizionario
questo questa è la definizione sintetica
del dizionario della lingua italiana
treccani ci accorgiamo leggendo che le
cose che ho detto per introdurre il
nostro incontro nostro dialogo non sono
esattamente tutte contemplate nella
definizione di nuovo caschiamo in quella
piccola vertigine attraverso la quale il
design è un operazione attraverso cui
produciamo oggetti materiali e di nuovo
immaginiamo di ricadere in quella
circostanza descrittiva per cui questi
oggetti materiali fanno una sorta di
percorso pendolare tra la forma e la
funzione non come nel moderno
nell'ambito del pensiero moderno si è
sempre pensato io ritengo che ci sia
qualcosa che sfugge qua dentro e che
forse le definizioni migliori non le
dovremo trovare nei dizionari ma noi
dovremo trovare in alcune storie io sono
un onnivoro appassionato collezionista
ma non di cose materiali di storie di
esseri umani sono quelle che mi
emozionano di più è quella che mi
ispirano di più
tra le tante questa sera vorrei provare
a condividere con voi una storia che
credo calzi a pennello per capire quanto
il mestiere del progettista possa
realmente cambiare la società
contemporanea
questo signore di cui propongo un nome
cognome e nome da nativo indiano
americano george gift alcuni lo chiamano
con lo ricordano come george gas più
noto come sequoia è sufficientemente
noto negli stati uniti d'america
credo misconosciuto nel resto del mondo
se non ad alcuni immagino che tra di voi
qualcuno conosca la storia di sequoia
volevo però ripercorrerla in sintesi per
parlare con voi del ruolo che se vuoi a
un essere umano ha avuto nei confronti
di una comunità
la sua chi era george bush era un
indiano un indiano delle americhe un
nativo americano dei territori
sconfinati nel nord sud caroline dakota
di quei territori che all'epoca stiamo
parlando del settecento alla fine del
settecento erano compresi nei domini
delle 28 grandi tribù che si spartivano
il territorio nordamericano le tribù
indiane appunto e george dista faceva
parte di una tribù che probabilmente
conoscete xkè tutti immaginiamo di
ricordare le grandi avventure narrate da
john ford dai registi del super quest ix
di hollywood
beh questo signore questo sequoia era un
indiano cherokee il cherokee erano per
estensione demografica la più grande
tribù del nord america
diciamo che quando è vissuto george gist
sequoia per l'appunto contavano circa
tra i 18 e 25 mila membri
ora perché parliamo di sequoia tanto da
iniziare poi tutti immaginiamo di sapere
che cos'è una sequoia no è un albero
enorme pochissimi di noi sanno che in
realtà l'albero si chiama così in onore
della persona di cui stiamo parlando per
ricordare la sua storia se poi era un
indiano che di mestiere faceva il fabbro
costruiva piccoli oggetti piccoli
utensili che è nei primi anni
dell'ottocento incominciava a scambiare
con i visi pallidi con i coloni
occidentali giunti nei territori dove
sequoia e alle sue tribù erano nate
scoprì in questa attività di commercio
che gli occidentali avevano una modalità
molto simili alla loro di dialogare di
scambiare informazioni di trasmettersi
informazioni in forma orale ma ne vedono
una che lo colpì molto
sembravano possedere il dono di
trasmettere il pensiero quasi in forma
telematica attraverso quelle che lui
chiama con una modalità molto poetica
secondo me ad talking lips cioè le
foglie parlanti che altro non erano che
appunti su pezzi di carta
l'uomo che colonizza va le sue terre era
in grado di prendere appunti su dei
fogli di carta lasciarli ad altri uomini
ed è in grado di parlare in sua assenza
una sorta di evento magico per gli
indiani tutti in particolare per sequoia
che fu molto colpito da questa cosa
tenete conto che gli indiani in quel
periodo avevano certamente sviluppato
una grande tradizione linguistica ma
l'eredità di queste lingue a veniva
trasmessa solo ed esclusivamente per via
orale non esisteva capacità di scrittura
non esisteva capacità di lettura in
breve gli indiani cherokee erano
analfabeti sequoia era un analfabeta
totale ma il suo spirito di osservazione
lo porta a immaginare che forse questi
pochi in ligue queste foglie che
parlanti non sono non erano diciamo così
un artificio magico quasi un atto di
stregoneria
ma c'era qualcosa dietro c'era una
capacità di sintesi una cultura in
qualcosa che l'ossessione per vario
tempo e quindi l'analfabeta sequoia
inizio a elaborare una modalità
attraverso la quale riuscire a
decodificare i suoni della lingua
cherokee in una forma scritta
tutto questo lo fece da in uno stato di
completa trans nel senso che nessuno era
riuscito a spiegare a george gist che la
lingua scritta era la trasposizione di
quella parlata visionariamente lo
immaginò e immagina di tradurlo con una
serie di geroglifici ora cinese molto
tempo ea 1 negli anni moltissimi
fallimenti non fu in grado assolutamente
di vincere al primo
colpo ma dopo 15 anni circa
se poi e riuscì a fare una cosa che
3.500 anni prima a sua assoluta senza
che lui lo sa perche avevano fatto i
cretesi cioè creò l'alfabeto sillabico
degli indiani cherokee
in buona sostanza fece corrispondere a
dei segni che erano delle lettere che
aveva copiato da un alfabeto occidentale
malamente anche alcune porzioni
linguistiche del lingua cherokee
dapprima i segni che traducevano queste
simboli erano 300 quello sci con lo
sforzo mirabile di sintesi a costruire
l'alfabeto sillabico perfetto 85 sillabe
85 simboli sequoia è stata nella storia
dell'umanità almeno di quella tra
scritta che è giunta fino a noi
l'unico essere umano analfabeta a creare
un alfabeto e a condividerlo con il suo
popolo
nel 1821 l'alfabeto e compiuto nel 1825
viene adottato dalla nazione dei
cherokee che si era già strutturata
all'epoca come una vera e propria
nazione e nel 1838 i cherokee hanno
addirittura un quotidiano che si
chiamava il cherokee fenix negli anni
quaranta dell'ottocento 25.000 uomini e
donne e bambini della nazione cherokee
erano completamente alfabetizzati ora
25.000 persone contro 22 milioni che
eravamo noi nel 1861 cioè poco più di
venti anni dopo gli eventi che vi sto
raccontando che avevamo noi italiani
nell'anno della nostra costituzione
certo sono un esiguo numero è certo non
si può comparare ma se vi dico che nel
1861 gli italiani erano per il 78 per
cento completamente analfabeti riusciamo
a cogliere l'entità del progetto di
sequoia che un progetto di design
sequoia è stato un grandissimo designer
a sua insaputa probabilmente perché
esercitato tutte le straordinarie
capacità di un ottimo designer spirito
d'osservazione d'analisi esigenze
computer disegno di un qualche cosa in
questo caso non solo una tipografia che
disegnò lui stesso ma il disegno di una
grande strategia per arrivare a quello
che in qualsiasi dizionario che
rifinisce termine sahin manca
praticamente sempre che il bene
collettivo
se poi e riuscì ad alfabetizzare un
intero popolo significa che riuscì a
donare loro la capacità di trasmettere
la memoria di trasmettere il pensiero di
produrre conoscenza e di condividerla
con gli altri per il futuro diede ai
cherokee un futuro la storia poi andò
diversamente come molti di voi sanno da
un punto di vista etnico diciamo così
per la sua tribù ma mi piace ricordare
che quest'uomo fu un uomo semplice che
rappresenta per me il miglior esempio
possibile per raccontare che cosa
dovrebbe essere un designer ancora oggi
nel 2000 e qui e 15 vorrei chiudere con
una citazione di un altro grande
misconosciuto norman botta nel 1969
questo signore in inghilterra scrive un
breve saggio che si intitola che cos'è
un designer lui faceva di mestiere
l'ebanista era un cabinet maker scrisse
un testo molto interessante molto bello
e lo chiuse dicendo che ero human beings
designer ogni essere umano è un designer
così come ci aveva insegnato sequoia
così come oggi per l'esempio migliore
possiamo ancora immaginare noi di usare
il design per il prossimo futuro
immaginare il design con una risorsa
strategica che cambia la società è ciò
che a me personalmente preme ma che
dovrebbe premere a tutti perché il mondo
di cui siamo circondati e progettato da
esseri umani se vi guardate intorno non
c'è nulla che non sia stato pensato da
qualcuno e che sia stato messo in opera
da qualcuno
penso che questo sia un pensiero molto
interessante immaginare che alcuni
individui alcuni esseri umani hanno
strutturato una modalità per arrivare in
maniera rivoluzionaria a condividere con
gli altri
il bene pubblico condividere a
conoscenza a poter trasmettere
empaticamente una visione sincera
coerente forte di collettività e io
credo che questo sia alla fine di tutto
il vero obiettivo rivoluzionario del
design di oggi e di domani
grazie